two minutes and 47 seconds of opening
credits with an owl screensaver hell
yeah David Bowie wait a minute
damn it this is 1980s David Bowie in
this case more opportunities for toy
money jennifer connelly isn't old enough
to be hot yet acting out something that
is going to be real later cliche hey
that's the title of the movie also roll
credits
[Music]
because she needs a man's voice to get
through to her
almost everything in Sara's room has
something to do with the movie later
accept Judge Dredd why is Judge Dredd so
prominent here my good god this girl is
always acting isn't she crying well
since we just sat through what felt like
ten hours of crying maybe he went to
sleep do you actually want to hear that
again he's only a half-brother don't
define him or I'll throw sneaky you that
turns into a harmless scarf you have 13
hours in which to solve the labyrinth
arbitrary deadline is arbitrary well
come on Sierra's feet are powered by
verbal commands puppet Aaron I thought
Huggle was killing these fairies since
he was counting eight when he sprayed
but apparently he's just counting how
many times he's been addictive fairies
you get seen Oh through the magical door
that wasn't there before children's
imaginations are so awesome thanks I
feel the same way about that school as
you do sir I liken me some fun guys
Sarah does her best take on me
impersonation with a labyrinth walls
sometimes when you read this clock nine
is six and six is nine and sometimes
it's capital L o clock also the clocks
can strike thirteen in this castle so I
guess George Orwell was right ah damn it
you're about to 1980's David Bowie are
you
this dance David Boies Family Jewels if
Sarah's imagining all this she can think
of things happening out of her sight but
make it so she's not aware these things
are happening that is incredible
objectivity for an imagination done baby
so is being in helpful hands creepy
uncle hell or creepy uncle heaven that's
racist this is where actors go when they
tear down the fourth wall they become
walls boggle is getting way too close to
the Bowie bolt for a kid's movie how you
enjoy my labyrinth
it's a piece of cake why would you say
this hmm when the Goblin Bowie threw
this crystal ball down the hallway I
thought he created a basic kill device
but it looks like this machine is
operated by little creatures doing their
everyday job and they look in no way
concerned as to whether or not they kill
anyone if this is a room with a ladder
why was the room even sealed in the
first place
well since this is a fantasy movie I'll
give this half a cent I don't know why
they're shot needed to be a special
effect but maybe it's because they
needed that hidden Bowie face in the
rock you can still knock without putting
that back in his mouth right I'm just
noticed your lovely jewels and missing
I wish Bowie's lovely jewels were
missing Gareth forgets to forget huggles
real name this fairy tale poison fruit
cliche bobble suddenly turns into Amos
and or Andy if she ever kisses you I'll
turn you into a prince prince of the
land of stench oh wait why am i laughing
again evil labyrinth trap Sarah in a
horrible blue-screen world this guy
swallowed his eyes another back in his
eye sockets this creatures digestive
system sends food to his eye sockets all
labyrinths come standard with safety
branches in case of unexpected fall how
did this asshole get down here okay so
Ludo has the power to summon rocks but
why did this particular rock come to the
rescue
why didn't other rocks come out of
nowhere and try to help did Ludo just
talk to this one rock well damn he
didn't even need to summon the first
rock it could have just told these rocks
to appear out of nowhere also how did he
know there was absolutely no rock
underneath Sarah but there were tons of
complementary rocks around her to form a
path also if these rocks have been
swimming around in the bog of eternal
stench wouldn't Sarah touching them mean
that she'll stink forever as the
doraville warned
you can't get a little bit stinky sure
rocks I wonder what the rocks get out of
this relationship Fox on the hound
we interrupt labyrinth to bring you this
David Bowie music video all it takes to
get out of the poison peach dreamworld
is taking a chair and smashing out of it
also what is the point of the poison
peach dreamworld if the victim can just
take something imaginary and smash
something imaginary to get out the to
imaginaries make a real this creature
with junk in the trunk was just standing
still doing nothing in particular until
sarah rudely got on her back did the
Skeksis Chamberlain just enter the movie
[Music]
take that Madonna and using my
imagination to try and figure out how
Ludo and sir didymus ended up in the
junkyard looking for Sarah but all I can
come up with is fire-breathing dragons
flew them here also I think it's because
they rolled a 14 with their d20 I smell
trouble I'd say not Nick Nolte is
probably miles away from here what the
hell happened was that an explosion did
Davy Bowie take up too much of this
movies budget let's get that rat who
calls himself Jerry can't jerath hear
what uncle just said why can't Jarrett
send him to the ball gap eternal stench
right now how the hell does Gareth not
know this has he been having so much fun
babysitting that he just forgot about
her and figured evil one I'm surprised
how many poop and pee jokes made it into
this Jim Henson production also this
joke is kind of wrong not only is the
fountain peeing but there's a cock right
next to it why would you say this okay
so is that it none of the other Knights
can attack sir didymus now this cannon
shoots it nothing in particular took a
while for these assholes to show up they
were like 5 feet away from him the whole
time sex um ex machina I love how Jim
Henson populates his worlds with little
details like this I'm gonna take the sin
away wait a minute is that a string I
see okay that's a sin I know we're
assholes David Bowie doesn't sing a song
to get out of this mess
the expression whoa Nelly these chains
don't do anything for any particular
security reason oh hell no Bowie you are
not singing your way out of this MC
Escher painting this time digital stunt
baby I'm not sure this is a kids movie
I'm gonna have to consult my Bruno
Bettelheim about Bowie bulges and female
centric fairy tales mmm cool the major
top stop-motion Jennifer Connelly I'm
guessing this is gonna require a lot of
therapy you'll smell bad
[Music]
I wish I wish I wish I wish I hadn't
killed that maid
[Applause]
[Music]
you fight with the strength of many men
tonight none shall pass I command you as
king of the Britons to stand aside I
move for no man deja vu is usually a
glitch in the matrix it happens when
they change something mr. Rao how many
licks does it take to get to the tootsie
roll center of a Tootsie Pop a good
question let's find out
[Music]
we have to face stupid reality again
shall we take a look at some paradoxical
architecture you're gonna have to master
a few tricks if you're gonna build three
complete dream levels excuse me in a
dream you can cheat architecture into
impossible shapes that lets you create
closed loops like the Penrose steps the
infinite staircase
paradox